some of the things that that i like to
remind people is we're the 28th largest
state population 19th largest land
area-wise we've got some of the cleanest
water cleanest air in the country we
have an all-of-the-above approach in
energy in other words we love oil and
gas
we're number six in oil production
number four natural gas but we're also
number two in wind energy production
so we have we're one of only four states
four states that 40 percent of our
energy comes from renewables and so it's
very attractive to a lot of companies
right now
i'm dave rubin and as you guys know i'm
off the grid for all of august but we
pre-taped a bunch of interviews for you
before i left the internet and joining
me today is the governor of oklahoma
governor kevin stitt welcome to the
reuben report
hey great to be with you thanks so much
hope you're having a great time on your
vacation when this is aaron
i hope that i'm having a great time too
not paying attention
to the news but i am looking forward to
chatting with you because we met a
couple weeks before i went off the grid
governor desantis held a little event in
florida for some governors and some
twitter personalities or whatever the
rest of us are uh and you you brought up
a couple interesting points and i
immediately went up to you after i said
we got a chat so so here we are so
before we do anything uh you know people
talk about oklahoma and most people
probably say hey what what's going on in
oklahoma i don't know much about
oklahoma uh so first why don't we just
get a little your personal history and
then we'll dive into some of the stuff
we need to know about oklahoma
absolutely well i'm the 28th governor of
the great state of oklahoma fourth
generation oklahoman and a business guy
i was never in politics when i ran in
2018
my story i grew up in norman oklahoma
where the university of oklahoma is
my dad was a pastor there and then but i
went to oklahoma state in stillwater for
college got an accounting degree
and then
started my company shortly after college
with a thousand dollars in a computer
and and live the american dream story
today we have sixteen hundred employees
uh do business all over the country and
uh i got inspired to run i watched a
businessman uh get elected president of
the united states and uh and and i saw
my state kind of struggling and i looked
and saw who was running it was just
more of the same really just career
politicians and and i said hey if
anything's gonna change we need business
people we need a fresh set of eyes we
need people like our founding fathers
envisioned that we're going to leave the
private sector go serve their country or
their state and actually change things
and focus on the next generation not the
next election and so
i told that to oklahomans when i
campaigned they agreed with me we won
the election and today oklahoma is
really exploding in growth we have
so many great things going we've got the
largest savings account we've ever had
we have the lowest unemployment i cut
taxes last year more people are moving
to oklahoma than ever before we're top
ten in the country in that and so things
are just really on the up and up for our
state we're the 28th largest state uh
population-wise right above uh texas
figurally and uh actually right above
texas so i like to point that out
so i think a lot of people watching this
are probably going wait a minute
oklahoma it can't have that many
problems that a successful business guy
has to run i mean we talk about
california's problems we talk about new
york's problems maybe illinois problems
i mean mostly blue state problems
what could possibly be going on in
oklahoma that is a successful guy i mean
you were running multi-million dollar
business would have to throw his hat in
the ring well when i when i say what i'm
talking about we had a teacher walkout
for example we weren't paying our
teachers what mark it was so i gave our
teachers a pay raise to bring them up to
market
government when government won't fix
itself they government always wants to
spend more so bringing that fiscal
discipline i believe in smaller
government i believe in lower taxes so
bringing some of those disciplines into
our state budget and running government
like a business
is kind of what i what i focused on we
there's 33 000 state employees in
oklahoma it's a 22 billion dollar budget
and normally they people hire
non-business people and people that have
never signed paychecks never set a
vision and hired the right people held
people accountable so those are all the
things that we brought to oklahoma and
so
things are moving
moving the needle we've deregulated our
business
setting a level playing field not
picking winners and losers so people
understand uh
you know
the great things about moving to our
state energy policy we have an all-above
energy approach and that's led to
the lowest cost of electricity to
business or consumer so keeping those
conservative values going even in a red
state like ours sometimes the
bureaucracy and the government can get
away from you and you've got to come in
with an outsider to bring it back and
check
i heard you talk a bit about this a
couple weeks ago but how did you deal
with all the the lockdown madness and
figuring out what to do and allowing or
not allowing people to live their lives
accordingly
well you know first off we believe in
freedoms in oklahoma and we believe in
our constitution and we're not going to
put our constitution in the attic
just because somebody in washington dc
says that we should do that
you know so we kept our state open the
entire time i kept our schools open i
wasn't going to
uh say this business is essential and
this business is not essential the only
non-essential business is one that you
didn't put capital in or you don't get
your paycheck from so picking winners
and losers like that uh to me is
un-american it's not right and what
we've done to our businesses and then
what we did to our kids by keeping them
out of school in these other states it's
just it's an atrocity so uh in oklahoma
we kept everything open
and and because of that now people are
realizing and recognizing the benefits
our businesses are are having their best
years ever and companies from california
are moving to states like ours
because they they're tired of the
mandates and
and the dictating from the
holier-than-now government officials
that we know best and do as we do as we
say so i think everyone watching knows
my story and you heard it at that event
we did i am a new floridian about seven
months in right now after living in
california and you mentioned you guys
are getting this influx of people and
businesses uh does that worry you ever
that you know these businesses come in
they bring a whole bunch of people
they've often voted the wrong way which
caused the problems in the first place
and now they have to integrate into a
new state that is basically doing it
right
you know we hear that a lot the the
folks that we meet from california you
know i have those conversations with
them i jokingly tell them hey i had to
wait 18 years to vote in oklahoma so i
expect you to wait 18 years before you
can vote
and uh but they take they go hey listen
here's the deal there's there's 12
million people in california that voted
for president trump the people that are
leaving are recognizing the differences
between a blue state and a red state and
so trust me they're saying we are on
your side we believe in freedoms we
believe in smaller government we live in
less regulation doing business in
california is an absolute beat down i
know that personally and from the
regulatory climate from the taxation
climate they're just so out of touch
with what our values are as oklahomans
and most of americans
that i think normal people are leaving
there
before we jump into some of the
specifics what else do people have to
know about oklahoma i feel like it's
just like one of those states that
people kind of they go through it they
maybe fly over it and and they don't
think about it that much but you guys
are doing an awful lot when it comes to
energy and a whole bunch more yeah well
i mean i was just uh in in farnborough
england representing our state for the
aerospace and defense industry and some
of the things that that i like to remind
people is we're the 28th largest state
population 19th largest land area-wise
we've got some of the cleanest water
cleanest air in the country we have an
all-of-the-above approach in energy in
other words we love oil and gas
we're number six in oil production
number four natural gas but we're also
number two in wind energy production uh
so we have we're one of only four states
four states that 40 of our energy comes
from renewables and so it's very
attractive to a lot of companies right
now
but we have the largest maintenance
repair facility on aviation in the
country with tinker air force base so
great aviation industry
we've got an inland port so most people
don't realize that about oklahoma we
have the farthest frost free port in the
country all the way almost to tulsa uh
so a lot of great things going we got
great agriculture
we feed the world in a lot of cases from
our from our agricultural side number
two beef producer in the country
so a lot of great things going and then
the freedoms
oklahoma city i think is the 25th
largest city in the country we've got
the thunder a professional sports team
so the quality of life the commute in
oklahoma is like 15 minutes compared to
an hour in some of the other major metro
areas so people love the quality of life
you've got to come visit oklahoma
and i'm guessing house prices a little
bit better than here in florida right
now
definitely definitely right i mean we
obviously are you know everything's
going up all over the country but our
we've got an arbitrage right now and
that's what businesses are seeing is
that they can come in and the quality of
life with the cost of living allows them
to pay less than you can on some of the
coast and and with covet you're seeing
people move and say and i don't have to
work in in this big city or through
technology we can live anywhere
but we're also seeing headquarters move
to dallas fort worth and move to
oklahoma city and move to other states
and get out of the the new york city
areas or the bay areas where crime is is
rampant and homelessness and all the
stuff that uh doesn't happen in our
state
you mentioned the amount of oil and gas
you guys produce and then also wind
power does that cause any tension in the
business community or any tension with
the federal government because they the
federal government at least seems to
view oil and gas versus wind as very
very different things they like one they
don't like the other
you know that's the thing that that
blows their mind whenever i go and meet
with the bide administration and their
secretary of energy and we talk about it
all the time those things can co-exist
together we believe in the free market
in oklahoma we believe in an
all-of-the-above approach
so they do co-exist just fine
we love our oil and gas industry and you
can't have an intellectually honest
conversation about the needs of
americans
and a reliable energy grid without
talking about natural gas and talking
about oil
but we don't shy away we're leaning into
hydrogen for example i signed an mou
with with the governor of arkansas and
louisiana we believe that we will get
one of the four hydrogen hubs
to prove out it's a two billion dollar
kind of program to prove out of
commercialization use of hydrogen
but you're going to need pipelines for
hydrogen development
we can coexist together and you can talk
about transition and you can talk about
oil and gas and again i we don't know
why that why there's such an attack on
the oil and gas industry from this
administration because what's their
alternative
is to buy oil from russia or saudi
arabia because demand is the same
and and here's something that i'd like
to point out to people every president
of the united states since 1973
has had an energy independence policy
whether they republican or democrat
until this administration and they
wanted to just cancel everything cancel
the keystone pipeline make drilling
impossible uh but they they
what they forget is we still have to
drive to work we have to heat our homes
our businesses we have to drive our kids
to soccer practice and football practice
and so the demand is the same and
they're not just they're not being
honest
do you think they yeah well that i think
is the part that do you think that they
actually are just simply not being
honest or this is by design that they
they know people have to go to work they
know people have to you know get in the
car but they are sort of telling us hey
we want off this stuff regardless of the
repercussions you know i hope that's not
the case uh but i've seen the reports
just like you that that they make these
statements like well we knew that prices
were going to be jacked up for a while
but
that's going to be part of the process
to get off of oil and gas
and i hope that's not true uh because to
harm oklahomans or to harm americans
just because you have some kind of
left-wing agenda
that's not the president that i would
hope would be representing our country
um but but you know i i don't know
what's happening because it doesn't make
common sense to most americans on why
they are burying their head in the sand
and and not having an honest
conversation when just a couple years
ago we were energy independent and
you're now seeing inflation skyrocket
everything cost more 40-year highs at
everything and actually they harm
they're harming the people
that they actually think that they're
protecting that's what people need to
understand is these policies from the
democratic party
actually hurt
average oklahoma middle income people
the rich get richer and it hurts
everyday oklahomans it's the republicans
it's a free market it's it's uh the
innovation of business that actually
helps the middle class grow
yeah
absolutely you're you're preaching to
the choir over here
my audience gets it uh anything else we
should know broadly about oklahoma
before i want to dive into some of this
stuff that i heard you talking about
about uh what's going on with the native
american reservations there which is
really fascinating but anything else you
want to get off your chest quick yeah no
i'm good i'm good we'll probably i'll
probably be circling back to it
okay so uh when i heard you speak a
couple weeks ago you told a really
fascinating story
and was describing some of the tension
that oklahoma faces over what's going on
with the native american reservations
there and how there is seemingly a
disparate uh
distance in the way laws are being
applied when it comes to native american
population
versus the average oklahoman you told a
couple anecdotes about that can you just
kind of give me the 101 on that yeah
absolutely well first off the mcgirt
decision came out in july of 2020 and
basically what it said it was the u.s
supreme court decision called mcgirt so
i'll encourage everybody to look it up
but basically it said
that we still had reservations in
oklahoma so
about half of our state was all of a
sudden turned back into an indian
reservation tulsa oklahoma with a
million people was now considered an
indian reservation and here's the deal
i'm not against the indians i'm actually
a member of the cherokee we're proud of
right you're literally you yourself
literally i can show you my card my
heritage i have indian blood so i have a
membership to the indian uh to the
cherokee nation so it's not an
anti-indian thing but this is a
pro-oklahoma thing this is a common
sense thing so what was happening is we
had tribal governments then saying that
they didn't have to follow the laws of
the state of oklahoma they were saying
that nope that if you were indian you
didn't have to pay taxes in oklahoma but
every other race did
they were saying that the district
attorneys couldn't prosecute crimes the
same way so you had a situation that you
didn't have fairness you didn't have
equal protection under the law and so i
fought like crazy uh against all odds
really because uh they're super powerful
they're using taxpayer dollars to get in
and influence races and try to run
negative ads against you et cetera et
cetera but i got a case back to the
supreme court and said listen we have to
be able to prosecute to protect public
safety uh all crimes in eastern oklahoma
and the castro vortex case just came out
since we talked i believe
that gave us a huge win and they said
yes you do have the right to prosecute
all crimes in oklahoma and furthermore
they said that indian reservations are
still part of a state and therefore
they're subject to state jurisdiction
which gives us a lot more certainty now
um than than we had once before so those
are all things that i think americans
need to be aware of because this would
be like uh the supreme court coming into
your city and your state and saying hey
this used to be indian land and so uh
you now you no longer have to follow
they don't have to follow zoning or
taxation laws you know those kind of
things that's how it threw us into a
kind of turmoil in our state
yeah well i would imagine that the
average citizen after the mcgirt
decision probably
it increased tension actually between
the communities right i mean if you're
just the law abiding citizen and now
someone breaks into your house or
whatever might be and then they're not
going to be prosecuted because of their
lineage i could see some tension
developing a hundred percent i mean we
we had we had district attorneys telling
people that if you have an indian tag on
your car
you need to park in the garage because
there were people targeting those people
because they knew that the state
couldn't prosecute those crimes
so it was just ridiculous i mean the
9-1-1 calls going into our 9-1-1 system
they were having to ask the question
well are you native or not and people
were like well do i have to tell you if
i'm native or not because then you won't
come out and and so it was all this
turmoil and i'm glad that the supreme
court did the right thing uh to to say
hey this is this is still a state uh we
have to be on equal footing with every
other state we have to be able to
regulate business and oil and gas and
and zoning and mining and and all the
things we can't turn that on to county
by county depending on uh you know what
indian tribe used to be located there
how was that for you with your
background having to go in and do
something that i'm sure a certain amount
of people thought you were a turn code
or there's probably words for it that we
need not mention on this show yeah you
know here's what i tell people i said 95
percent of native americans like me that
have part native blood we're proud of
that but we're american and we're
oklahoma first so they actually agreed
with me it was only those at the very
top of the tribe uh the big bosses that
were really fighting us and putting
money against us one tribe said they
were going to stop flying the oklahoma
flag
on their land which then the citizens
really revolted and he quickly changed
his tune that chief did
like two days later and said oh okay
well i decided i would keep flying the
oklahoma flag so they they took it too
far and and and you know stings have a
tendency if the pendulum swings too far
people go hey this doesn't feel right
and it comes kind of back to balance and
and we believe that's why the supreme
court brought that case back
let me ask you as a native american that
means automatically you have to
represent all native americans how do
you feel about you know when they have
the atlanta braves or the washington
redskins you know it usually seems like
it's a bit of a media construct but
obviously everyone has their own
feelings oh listen
we're so sensitive it doesn't bother me
a bit every single person like me 10 of
oklahoma's population are native about
400 000
and uh
you know i think the media blows out a
portion it's just like anything it's a
very small vocal minority and what's
disappointing is these businesses and
these professional teams just end up
caving uh you know for for
for you know a very small vocal minority
and i know that's kind of the where
we're at today but i think the bigger
point to me is
we we believe in america in in in based
on your merit your hard work and your
education and your
how hard you want to work depends on
your success not the color of your skin
or your nationality i want a system that
is fair for everybody and doesn't pick
winners and losers and i think when we
try to uh pay people off or give money
to this race or or try to quote unquote
right this wrong i think those are those
are bad precedents and it'll it'll end
up breaking our country and it divides
us further
do you sense we're we're divided sort of
in an irreparable fashion i mean when
you talk about freedom and capitalism
and limited government and all those
things that yeah that's happening in red
states it really is it seems to be
strengthening in certain states
certainly the two states that we're in
but it's not happening in blue states
and it doesn't seem like it's going to
turn around in blue states what do you
think about that tension going forward
as the united states of america
you know i mean that that's the
million-dollar question
you know you you look back to our
leaders like you know ronald reagan and
it felt like he could bring people
together and kind of talk about
capitalism and the exceptionalism of
america
in a way that kind of brought us
together and revitalized our country and
so we hope that we can get back there uh
because i believe that the majority of
americans think like i do we we believe
in in
we believe in god and i think you take
god out of the values and we believe in
uh we were founded our country on these
biblical values uh we believe in freedom
of religion uh that means we don't
discriminate against any religion but we
certainly don't discriminate it we can't
discriminate against the christian faith
either
and so i i think that most people
believe in family and and and capitalism
and and and you have to work hard and
let's create a level playing field for
everybody to go succeed and it's just
disappointing when some people think
that the answer is government handouts
and they think that the answer is
more government and more taxes
that's just you can look across history
you can look at other other countries
that have tried that model and and i
think that's failing and but i think
that i still believe that the majority
of americans think like we do so if we
say this in a in a correct way
uh and
i believe that's the winning message
yeah i'm with you how have you guys done
when it comes to all of the woke stuff
keeping the the gender stuff and the the
critical race theory all of that out of
the schools or has it seeped in and and
what are you doing about it you know
again sometimes that tries to seep in
what i've done about it is i
was the first governor in the country
that passed the build that bans critical
race theory uh and and the media kind of
calls it critical race theory but here's
all my bill said it's it just simply
said that in our school system
uh we're not going to teach that one
race or one sex is superior to another
race or another sex that's all it says
and i don't know how you can argue huh
old school old school how can you argue
with that let's teach our kids not
indoctrinate them and teach them that
they're inferior because of the color of
their skin or they're somehow
responsible for something that happened
100 years ago i'm not going to teach
that to a first grader this is that's
ridiculous uh and so
i also signed the the save women and
sports bill which to us in oklahoma i
mean we don't know what's going on with
the rest of the country because for us
it's like everybody applauds me that
we're gonna have we're going to protect
women's sports and athletics and girls
are going to play in girls sports and
boys are going to play in boys sports uh
i'm not going to let a biological male
compete in high school against a a
female that's been training her whole
life where he has physical advantages on
the track or or in the swimming pool uh
against that girl and it's just it
doesn't make sense to us in oklahoma so
it's easy for me to sign these kind of
bills
is there any pushback on that stuff in
oklahoma you get anything i mean
you get some the the whacked out folks
but uh it's a very small small minority
here
yeah
what else is going on uh since you're
talking so much about business and that
really is your your background and
you've mentioned the sort of low you
know
less regulation and that sort of thing
what else is going on in in the business
world if someone's watching this in cali
right now and they're thinking about
getting out and i get emails every day
from cali people on the way out and i'm
usually selling them on florida but if
they want to stop before they get here
and see what's going on
you got to stop i mean listen florida's
second place compared to oklahoma okay
you might have a little bit of the ocean
but
if you want to make money and you want
to be
and you want the quality of life
oklahoma's the right spot to be but
you know technology companies we're
going hard after i'm looking at where
the
research and development dollars are
headed where we just landed a huge huge
electric vehicle manufacturer we're
going after that supply chain around
electric vehicles we have more electric
vehicle charging stations per capita
than any other state level three
charging stations so we're leaning into
that stuff most people go well
oklahoma's just oil and gas simply not
true i mean we love our oil and gas and
we are we are making sure that we do our
part for our country on our oil and gas
side but we're also uh not naive to
where the r d dollars are headed they're
not in combustible engines anymore
they're in electric vehicles uh so we
are all in there uh we're going into
hydrogen we just we we are we're looking
at that transition and and what type of
other energy sources can we have and as
as as california's having rolling
blackouts we have the cheapest
electricity cost to the business uh in
the country
yeah it's nice to hear things are going
right sometimes right i mean so what are
your headaches then i mean what are what
are really the headaches you're giving
me a pretty rosy picture of a state and
you seem like things are pretty sensible
there and all that stuff you must have a
couple headaches well i've got a couple
teenage daughters so uh if you could
help me i've got six kids and uh
six kids
yeah my wife and i we've been married 24
years we have six children our oldest is
21 down to eight
uh so just like just like every every
business person or or mom that's having
to work you have to balance uh you know
your your home life and raising your
kids and being a good husband and a good
father as well as your day job which my
day job happens to be governor of the
state uh so it's all it's always busy
but uh it's fun it's an honor of a
lifetime to serve your state where your
your grandparents grew up and i pinched
myself thinking about my granddad who
had an eighth grade education he was a
dairy farmer in skytook oklahoma and now
his son is uh his grandson is governor
so i just i get i just want to work my
tail off and make sure i leave my state
the best
the best possible state it can be when i
come back to the private sector
you couldn't give me anything other than
the kids so just all right so you're in
a pretty functioning state that seems
seems like things are going pretty well
the woke stuff's not getting in you got
business you got natural resources and
all of those things was there anything
when you came in as a businessman to
learn how government operates and look
at budgets and the way they spend and
all that stuff were you just pulling
your hair out i'm trying to get
something here that might have
frustrated you along the way well i mean
i don't really want my legislature to
see this but you know working with the
legislature has been difficult uh you
know number one i'm trying to get school
choice done across the finish line i
think that's the issue that would uh
turn our state around we want to empower
parents
not just the zip code that a kid has to
happen to be born in or live in at this
time and i tell people all the time
school choice should not be for the rich
it should be for everyone and these are
these are kids in oklahoma
and there's 700 000 kids let's make sure
we educate them and we give them the
best opportunity we've put parents back
in charge so trying to get that across
finish line is is a goal of mine if i'm
fortunate what kind of pushback do you
get on that because i would imagine in a
red state i mean there's so much
momentum behind that right now i can't
imagine it's too much right well we did
not get it across the finish line this
past session i hopefully we can next
year but really the rule folks uh that
and they're right in the fact that there
aren't a lot of the private schools but
those aren't the schools we're talking
about
a lot of it it's the inner city it's the
large school districts that are
indoctrinating the kids and and then you
have to try to you get parents that are
showing us the books that they're
teaching you can't micromanage every
single school district so let's inject
competition let parents choose where to
send their kids to school whether it's a
christian school or a catholic school or
a or a uh a charter school we need more
of that in our state so that that's
definitely a challenge uh to try to get
to cross the finish line for our for our
state uh budget process
uh it's got its own challenges i'm
always trying to hold our budgets flat
and sometimes you you fight with uh with
with some of the legislature that wants
to wants to grow government to be quite
honest with you
and you know you have to you have to
really hold that in check because we're
always nobody it seems like fights for
the taxpayer
you've got all these lobbyists and all
these industries will come in and hire
folks that advocate for their industry
but nobody advocates for the taxpayer
and that's my job that's what i tell
them hey i'm here fighting for the
taxpayer let's hold budgets flat let's
make sure that we give money back to the
taxpayer in the form of lower taxes
how much coordination do you do with
some other red state governors because
the event that we were at it was kind of
off the record at first but of course
the media gets it and then they
announced everybody that was there is
what it is but you know there are
obviously a bunch of other red state
governors there and it seemed like you
guys kind of talked some of this stuff
out i don't know if it's official but
you know really go back and forth on it
had a lot to do with covid lockdowns and
how maybe you would do it going forward
if they tried to pull anything else but
is there a lot of coordination on on
that kind of stuff or other issues you
know uh i think there is uh i would i
would call it a lot uh republican
governor association i think is the
greatest organization as far as
political action group in the country so
i meet with those governors probably
three or four times a year we all have
each other's cell phones so we'll text
each other and and i'll call billy in
tennessee by the way you know for
example and say hey what are you doing
on this or hey i saw something in the
paper about you know tennessee's doing
this can you can you walk me through
your thought process so we take ideas
from each other for sure and then we uh
we bounce uh you know kind of what we're
seeing in our state with one another so
it's a great collegial group uh that
we're able to meet and kind of going
through the same thing together covid
was a gut punch for all of us
so we were all
getting getting hammered from the media
on you know demanding it on lockdown i
was one of the only governors in the
country that refused to do a mask
mandate for example statewide
and just got hammered by the media so we
we've got a liberal you know fake news
media here in oklahoma too
ah finally i got something i got
something okay i don't know why that
gives me a little bit of joy it can't be
that perfect there you know i'm loving
florida these days all right well you're
going to appreciate what i'm going to do
right now because i am also a capitalist
and a free market guy so i'm going to
thank you for joining me on the show and
then we're going to i'm going to ask you
one more question perhaps the most
important question about republican
leadership going forward we're going to
do that exclusively for our subscribers
so we're going to wrap up this one and
go right over to the locals community so
governor kevin stitt i thank you for
joining us if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell